[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le skyco le
magazine qui vous raconte l'actualité
économique du territoire de 50 ans en
Yvelines dans ce numéro nous reviendrons
sur les rencontres entre des entreprises
vivinoises et des donneurs d'or des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris
2024 organisé au vélo Drôme national et
enfin nous partirons à la rencontre de
Gervais le sage cette entrepreneur qui a
lancé pragmasola installé à 50 ans ni
minuit cette entreprise permet à des
voisins de se regrouper pour acquérir
des panneaux solaires à des prix
attractifs
[Musique]
et je vous remercie en tout cas d'être
aussi nombreux ce matin puisque vous
êtes une centaine d'entreprises avoir
répondu à l'appel de top départ pour une
journée riche en découvertes jeudi 31
mars une journée de rencontre B2B est
organisée au vélo de route nationale
entre des entreprises yvelinoises et des
donneurs d'ordre des Jeux Olympiques et
par olympiques de Paris 2024 le
programme de la journée donc se déroule
en on va dire en trois temps ce matin
donc présentation des différents
donneurs d'ordre pour la avant la
rencontre en B2B de chacun qui se
déroule l'après-midi et en parallèle des
ateliers pour les entreprises et
notamment des ateliers pour aider les
entreprises à essayer de comprendre
comment on peut répondre non pas seul
parce que parfois on n'a pas la taille
critique mais répondre en consortium
avec avec plusieurs entreprises dans
cette salle c'est le speed meeting près
de 90 entreprises y vinoises dans les
secteurs de la sécurité de la
restauration et de la logistique ont
présenté leurs activités le but se et
retenir la tension des donneurs d'ordre
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est du sourcing
ce qu'on appelle du sourcing qualifié
c'est à dire partir à l'encon des chefs
d'entreprise non seulement leur
expliquer les marchés qui vont les
appels d'or qui vont être lancés et où
se situe nos besoins et ensuite c'est de
les rencontrer l'une des ambitions
fixées par la direction des Jeux
Olympiques et de favoriser l'accès aux
entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire on est un petit peu un des
outils de ces deux des deux grands
organisateurs des Jeux pour atteindre
leurs engagements donc voilà ils ont
pris des engagements sur le plan
environnemental et social et donc du
coup nous on les aide à atteindre ces
engagements prochain rendez-vous le 7
juin cette fois-ci pour faire découvrir
à des étudiants du digital collège les
disciplines qui seront pratiqués aux
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris 2024
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Gervais leage je
suis front d'acteur de pragmasola Pragma
solar accompagne les particuliers dans
leur démarche vers une installation
photovoltaïque
[Musique]
Pragma solar donc propose au niveau d'un
quartier à des particuliers de se
regrouper entre eux donc dans le but de
faire une accusation groupée d'une
installation enfin d'installation
solaire individuelle donc c'est chacun
dispose de son installation solaire mais
on le fait dans une démarche commune
[Musique]
la démarche de ce regrouper entre
particuliers entre voisins permet au
niveau d'un quartier par exemple d'avoir
une homogénétaire chez culturale au
niveau des toits ça permet de se
rassurer ça permet d'être en confiance
avec un installateur et du côté de
l'installateur local lui salue permet
effectivement d'avoir un groupe de
clients et d'avoir une démarche assez
claire pragmatique et économique aussi
puisqu'on arrive à avoir des coûts
d'installation qui sont de 10 à 15%
moins cher que si le particulier faisait
une installation on va dire solo tout
seul dans son coin
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a travaillé déjà sur
plusieurs quartiers donc il y a deux qui
sont réalisés donc avec différentes
installations sur chacun de ces
quartiers donc c'était une démarche de
dire assez convivial même entre voisins
[Musique]
ce serait également de travailler donc
sur des d'autres types de groupements il
y a une synergie par exemple à avoir
avec
les pompes à chaleur panneaux solaires
plus pompe à chaleur c'est quelque chose
qui fonctionne très bien ensemble et qui
améliore le processus économique les
véhicules électriques et le soleil aussi
améliore le système économique donc
voilà on peut multiplier entre la
production et l'usage de l'électricité
et
justement aussi travailler au niveau des
entreprises et des collectivités dans
des systèmes qui seraient d'échanger de
l'électricité entre les particuliers les
entreprises et les
collectivités et ça c'est un autre
système qu'on appelle l'autoconsommation
collective donc ça on est au tout début
de l'aventure
[Musique]
le ski cube nous a accompagné dans toute
la démarche de création d'entreprise et
dans la réflexion autour du marché de
l'approche client donc avec un
accompagnement qui a été fait par des
professionnels des entrepreneurs donc
c'est tout à fait intéressant de ce
confronter avec ses pairs
[Musique]